Almost every project I've done since Harry Potter. Oh, I felt really rescaled to start oh my god
If I don't do this
nothing else makes sense like I
I don't want to spend my time doing anything other than making sure that this maybe gets made. They say that every
Saint you know has a past and every sinner has a future and
It's so true
What's that believe nation?
It's Evan my one word is
Believe and I believe in you and I want to see that great thing that you have inside of you
Come out, so you can help change the world so to help you in your journey today
We're going to learn from actress model and activist Emma Watson and my take on her top 10 rules for success
rule number 9 is my personal favorite
And I'd love to know which one you guys like the best and as always guys as you're watching if you hear something that really
resonates with you
Please leave it down in the comments below and put quotes around it so other people can be inspired and when you write it down
It's much more likely to stick with yourself as well enjoy
What I know about Bell is that she's kind of if you look at her within the sort of the category of those Disney characters
She's kind of the rogue
She's a she kind of like she she takes a different course
That was always what I loved about Belle like when I think about Belle. I think about her singing
Belle reprieves, which is her sort of coming out of her house and singing this song, which is just kind of like
Bursting out of her which is you know I?
Know everyone around me can't understand why I don't want what everyone else thinks that I should one and which is being handed to me
But I really just want something more. I want something else
Like I don't this doesn't fit
I don't fit she kind of liked the Robert Frost poem she she takes the road less traveled and I
Always really identified with that. She's
Bala's no sheep. She's really on her own just on her own path. She's friends with sheep though. It's fast sheep
she is special she but she's on her own thing and there's this like defiance and I
just that that energy that spirit was really what I identified with in her being a
Child star as they call it or having worked as a miner
You do you do sort of have to be aware of the of the
Of the kind of trajectory and also kind of
Aware the that people are viewing your performances through a very different lens
It's I saw a really interesting article yesterday that you know people had seen the trailer and they're like
oh
you know Emma Watson like
Scandalous like really trying to push the push the envelope and step away from her mining Harry Potter and whatever else and it's like
I'm just kissing someone you know and it's kind of like this huge deal, and it's so you know you're aware of that
But you also I don't
Like to try and let all of that noise
affect my choices and like decisions because ultimately
if you live like that then you you know, I think it would it would close me off to a lot of opportunities and and
Experiences there's a lot of young actors and musicians today. They they kind of spin out of control a little bit
Why are you so good at just like?
Making your career is amazing and you're just making the right decisions later. Oh, thank you. That's pretty nice to hear um I
Guess I just I've just been really lucky in a sense that I've been offered a really diverse and interesting
range of roles and
I've just tried to do things that slightly terrify me every time. I guess I mean most almost every project
I've done since Harry Potter
I've I felt really reese cared to start so I've just kept trying to challenge myself really I
play Nicki in The Bling Ring and
how perfectly Nicki Nicki
writes yoga, and cheese cleanses and
She teaches pole dancing. She's this very complex girl and character
Stylist she was kind of boyish kind of a tease and it's kind of like nothing I've done before
To research the part, I learned pole dance I watched a lot of reality television I did
Yoga, I did a lot of thinking about how?
You'd get into the mindset where you would think that stealing is okay?
it was really important to me that I felt like I understood her and I could relate to her and
she felt like a real person you had a choice of you went to college and
And you had a choice than to either continue acting or pursue
Something else you
Majored in English literature right what made you decide that acting was then going to become the main event and not just something you
Used to do puck sipping a Wallflower really really yeah
It's so funny because I I went to college and I was genuinely kind of like well
I'm gonna go study, and then I'll all kind of like I'll see what happens and then
Steve sent me the script for Parks having a Wallflower, and I went and I sat down with him
And it just we ignited there, so I was like had you read the book before you really know
I hadn't so I read the book, and it just gave me this weird compulsion. I was like I have to tell this story
You know I oh my god
If I don't do this
Nothing else makes sense like I I don't want to spend my time doing anything other than making sure that this movie gets made
I must go to Pittsburgh Pittsburgh. I must get funding for this movie. You know and it's like
And it was really strange because I just didn't know
Coming out of Harry Potter whether I was going to feel that way about anything else for a long time
You know I had loved performing and I had loved acting
But really a big part of the passion for me was that I would just loved those stories
And I wanted to be part of that world. I loved that who that that character was and
It wasn't so much for me about the idea of being an actress
it was the idea of
like I just want to be part of this and
Perks and working with Steve and
Feeling that I had something else to give and offer was what really?
Was already did that for me everyone has a story everyone has
People intent tend to judge and interpret behavior without going to the source of that behavior
Like they say that every
Saint you know has a past and every sinner has a future, and it's so true you can't I
Don't know people can change and and people make mistakes and people are human
and you kind of need to love them for love them for that and
I
hope that people take that away finding a way to love their imperfections and love themselves and
Really, you can't truly
Accept other people until you accept yourself
And you can't really accept yourself until you accept other people it kind of all weirdly goes hand-in-hand and when you show
Kindness and compassion for yourself, then you're able to extend it and it's all it's all
Inextricably linked I made these movies. You won't find that but also you've done so well with all your great
So this sounds kind of odd number you've got eyes and all your GCSE
Is that way and in your higher levels as well yeah Wow congratulations?
Yeah, and it was tough, it was really tough. I felt very tall, but um it was so worth it you know
I'm so excited about going to university and you know I just
Won't have my cake and eat it. I want I want the best of both worlds
I want to do everything the difficulty which means I'm interested in so many different things
I can never really imagined myself doing one thing, and I'm pretty sure that I'll end up
Doing four or five different things. I want to be a Renaissance woman. That's my that's my thing
I want to paint and I want to write
And I want to act and I want to just do everything how do I drop my career and become an actor?
what do you think that's awesome you seem like the kind of person you would want to watch I want to be a
Film director do what you love and make films about what you love you can argue yourself into making decisions that
Don't have heart behind them
And then never the right ones just always follow the theme that feels the most right to you
There's something about humor to me, which speaks to humility which which speaks to
yeah to being humble to being human to
It's such a way to connect people and I think as long as you're not taking yourself too, seriously
mm-hmm nothing can go too badly wrong now obviously talking at the UN is an
Incredibly nerve-racking thing to do I imagine I'm not going to only imagine. I haven't actually spoken at the UN yet
They haven't asked me yet, but what what was the the mission statement?
What was going through your head in the morning of that speech? What was the mission statement you wanted to get across?
I guess I really wanted to communicate that
Gender equality historically has been predominantly a woman's movement for women, but I think
The impact of gender inequality, and how it's actually been affecting men
Hasn't really been addressed
So I really wanted to make
That one of the clearest messages in my speech men don't have the benefits of equality
either
We don't often talk about men being imprisoned by gender stereotypes, but I can see that they are
And that when they are free
Things will change for women as a natural consequence
If men don't have to be aggressive in order to be accepted
Women won't feel compelled to be submissive. If men don't have to control
Women won't have to be controlled
Both men and women should feel free to be sensitive
Both men and women should feel free to be strong it
Is time that we all perceive gender on a spectrum?
instead of two sets of opposing ideals
If we stop defining each other by what we are not and start defining ourselves by who we are
we can all be freer and
This is what Heath is about
It's about freedom I
Want men to take up this mantle so that their daughters sisters and mothers can be free from prejudice?
but also so that their sons have permission to be vulnerable and human to
Reclaim those parts of themselves they abandoned and in doing so
Be a more true and complete version of themselves
You might be thinking who is this Harry Potter girl
What is she doing speaking at the UN, and it's a really good question. I've been asking myself the same thing
all I know is that I care about this problem, and I want to make it better and
having seen what I've seen and
given the chance I
Feel it is my responsibility
to say something
Statesman Edmund Burke said
All that is needed for the forces of evil to triumph is for good men and women
to do nothing
In my nervousness for this speech and
in my moments of doubt
I've told myself firmly
If not me who
If not now when
If you have similar doubts when opportunities are presented to you I
Hope that those words will be helpful
Because
The reality is
That if we do nothing it
will take
75 years or for me it to be nearly a hundred
Before women can expect to be paid the same as men
For the same work. I am inviting you to step forward to
Be seen and to ask yourself
If not me who
if not now when
Thank you very very much
How did you feel after you've done, it, did you feel like you absolutely got every point across
Did you feel that that was that was the nice?
I love a lovely moment like one of the most surreal moments of my life. I have to say I remember
At the end of it seeing people start to stand up and it was
Like something from a dream or a film or I thought maybe I died, and it was
Irish it was just really surreal
We didn't die I didn't die um but kind of a little bit
I felt like I could I sound really cheesy, but I felt like I could sort of die happy like had sort of
Done kind of what the most important thing I might ever do I?
I had I had I would I was shaking I was so nervous
But at least I I got it out there like I'd managed to manage to voice the words
I've managed to I'd managed to get it out. I have to are you're an amazing freestylers
You just can just do this you're an amazing beat boxer. This is great
I eat books that cave it show me how what am I doing? Okay? Just well first let's to see no instruction
Oh just from what you've seen I know you've seen a lot of feed boxing
I'm sure they were beat boxing on set during those movies every young man
We just we just beat box
Okay, this could be so bad to be awesome. Do I cover my mouth. Yeah just for my sake yeah
Yeah, yeah, he's like this bit dark so
Embarrassing okay, what am I freestyling about gender equality fantastic? It's you it's International Women's Day
Let's see fishy into other quick feminism. I know feminists. Yeah absolutely. I love that
Okay, so what kind of beat do you want slow or fast? Whatever you?
Yeah, yeah, what's link, and I have to laugh how can we meet not easy to we like like women are like
All day every day every way oh
My gosh
Stick this way to find them you know I'm drastically changing the narrative. You know my gosh
I love watching this keep flowing. Holy cow this is such a meme. Thank you. This is the beatbox Dream Team
Love you, thank you beatboxing everyone go see the play and no one ever asked me to do that
Thank you guys so much for watching
I made this food because rowdy Janie asked me to if there's a famous
Entrepreneur that you would like me to profile next check out the link in the description and go and cast your vote I'd also love
To know what did you learn from this video that had the biggest impact on you?
What lesson you're going to take and immediately apply it somehow in your life or in your business leave it in the comments below?
I'm really curious to find out I also want to give a quick shout out to Robert Paladini Robert
Thank you so much for picking up a copy of my book your one word and tweeting at me and giving me that really kind
Message I really really appreciate this board, and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book. Thank you guys again for watching
I believe in you. Hope you continue to believe in yourself and whatever your one word is much. Love I'll see you soon
Handing off Hermione Granger to Nomo duma's whene'er on mm-hmm Harry Potter in the cursed child yeah, you've met her and yes
What were conversations like about Hermione? It was so emotional?
seeing nomás performance in a way that I
had not anticipated
At all I went to the play like really just like oh no this will be great. I'll be introducing and
didn't even realize until she walked in the room and
just
Spontaneous just burst into tears. It was such an emotional moment for me
I can't tell you, but it made me it was such a relief
Because I think I'd played that character, so intensely up until that point
To know that Hermione was gonna be okay. I know it sounds crazy. We're like to know that
everything turned out alright and
The wall everything in the world was okay
and that there was someone else carrying her on and carrying her forward and
It was just such a relief it made me so happy because otherwise I don't know what
Playing someone that I mean we get that little flash forward at the end of the last film but playing someone that
Kind of just gets stuck in time at 20
20 years old 19 years old was like no. I like I wanted her to have a future well
You see so many years of her life back to back to back and then yeah nothing so yet
So it was sort of a relief yeah
It was a relief now. Did you have any conversations with Pedro hara who voiced the character no?
the
Animated a it's interesting
I've done a few movies where I play
You know someone play my character before all that you know my character exists in real life, and I've always chosen
I've always chosen not to
I think because
In the act of creation you do you want to make sure that you're that you're bringing something
individual and original and a big part of it was
Wanting to stay faithful to the to the original telling
And I think I hope we really got the balance right of being like okay?
We're gonna offer you some new stuff that you've never seen before, but we're also going to give you the heart of theory
It's really quite shocking really fir because this is something so out of character
And we've never he seen that side to her before look who's here ah come see the show you
Know
Such a good moment and
The fact that she hits him for the fist, and it's not like a spell or something
It's actually like a physical hit. There's something very satisfying about that actually originally said in the script that Hermione slaps Draco
I think they were worried that a punch was going to be a little too
physical so I said to him I don't want to run this we should rehearse it we should make this as
Convincing as possible slapped me. She's like now. I'm not gonna say let's go on slap me right now
Let's just do this to good emotions what I said slapped me. I was like movie slap me
I probably should what I feel terrible I feel really bad. I'm not really sure what I was thinking
She just went and just smacked me right across the face which completely took me. I didn't know what to do
I was just like yeah, that was that was really good. That was that was great and kind of walked off sheepishly